I'm Dan Felder the head of R&D firma
murphy goo Madrid offer shefte disease
Momofuku sambar to the Momofuku culinary
lab started three years ago it's an
opportunity for us to develop a space
that's just about creativity and working
with fermented foods and traditional
products that we use a ton in our
restaurants things like soy sauce and
miso and bigger as the lab started out
small they're first getting a few
different things
dan would come here bring us lots of
little vials of different bodies and
hose onto things for us to taste a vast
range of unique flavors and products
that were able to create dishes around
one example is the porgy dish we've had
on the menu for a long time and in
different iterations dan brought me some
small pond Jesus and freckie box and
Faro Bungie we sat down we're tasting
the dot the just the basic grilled fish
dashi adding different quantities of the
different bodies and different until we
find something that you know wow that's
cool that's really interesting that's
flavorful that's unique for the arctic
char what we were into doing is we're
serving with pine nuts and we were
seasoning it with a little bit of Shiro
dashi just to add that a little bit of
umami flavor to it now instead of using
the Shiro dashi we're using a fermented
pine nut product supplied from the lab
and that gives us that in a sense the
amino acid do you mami flavor but
instead of in a sense diluting the pine
nut flavor we're ramping that pine nut
flavor up that moment is one of the most
fun for us to see what Matt and guys
ATCO and noodle and ma Peche then go and
make we've really only scratched the
surface so that's exciting to see
because we're tasting things that we
really haven't tasted before
you